okay so the topic of this video today is
some of the basics about the immune
system you know you can see three
examples of reasons why we need to
understand our immune system on the left
is the bacteria that causes tuberculosis
and the top right is the fungus that
causes athlete's foot and in the bottom
right it's probably one of the most
devastating viruses of all time the
influenza virus causes the flu so let's
go ahead and get started
looking at our our immune system okay so
you might know that our immune system
helps fight off pathogens and just in
general pathogens are typically
microorganisms that cause disease and
let's break it down into a few
categories pathogens into a few
categories viruses you know later on in
the year we'll learn more particular
more specifics about viruses but for now
I just want you to know that viruses
will actually turn your cells into
basically virus making factories
ultimately ending in the death of your
cells well study virus is in more detail
another chapter so another type of
pathogen would be bacteria and now
remember that bacteria are prokaryotic
cells they lack a nucleus but what makes
bacteria pathogenic is that many of them
will release toxic chemicals and when
those toxic chemicals build up and build
up and build up over time they can cause
various sicknesses the picture you see
here is the bacteria that causes the
disease tuberculosis if we look at this
x-ray of a person's chest this person
has tuberculosis and so look at the left
side of the picture the lung on the left
side of the picture looks black and
that's good because it's filled up with
basically air but look at the lung on
the right side of the picture now even
though it's the right side of the
picture this is actually the person's
left lung but notice it looks different
it's not filled up with black air it's
got this cloudy white area that's
because this lung on the right side of
the picture is filled up with mucus and
pus and phlegm it's a sign that the
person is very sick with tuberculosis
and let's see here is a fungus fungus
are another type of pathogen when fungal
cells feed let's say they're growing on
dead leaves well when fungus cells feed
they will pierce the cells of the dead
leaves and absorb the nutrients that are
in the dead leaves now that's fine and
dandy if the leaves are dead and the
cells are dead but some fungi can be
parasites and will actually feed on
living cells so the fungus in the
picture this is the fungus that causes
athlete's foot you can see this picture
of in between a person's toes the skin
is all cracked and dry well the fungus
cells that the fungus that is living in
this person's foot cells has pierced
their cells and is absorbing the
nutrients from the inside of the cells
causes a very itchy burning painful
sensation the good news is there are
various topical creams and sprays that
can treat athlete's foot and you know
ultimately kill the fungus another type
of pathogen are what are called
protozoans these are single-cell and how
are they different from bacteria then is
bacteria single-celled protozoan are
eukaryotes and bacteria are prokaryotes
so protozoans are single-cell eukaryotes
so in the picture here these purple
these purple shaped protozoans this is
again highly magnified right here in
this picture but these purple protozoans
are a type of protozoan by the by the
name of Plasmodium and this Plasmodium
parasite causes malaria and you can see
here from the table just some of the
signs and symptoms of malaria and in
areas of the world where malaria is more
common you can see this map right here
the the red areas show where where
malaria is more of a threat you can see
it's more of a threat in you know
tropical areas of the world but even
though you know we may not have a big
malaria threat here in the USA for those
of you who might travel to tropical
areas this could be a concern and then
there's just the the parasites in
general and so here's a tape
you may have heard of tapeworms well
here's a tapeworm egg and you might
accidentally ingest this perhaps in meat
that's not cooked properly cooked
thoroughly and so you might ingest
the tapeworm egg well over time that egg
is gonna grow into a tapeworm and the
tapeworm is probably hanging out inside
of your intestines and so here's a
drawing of at the top of the drawing is
the head of the tapeworm the head is
called a scolex by the way let's zoom on
in when we zoom on in here's a real neat
picture of the head or the scolex of a
tapeworm you notice it's got those hooks
on top while those hooks actually anchor
the tapeworm into your intestinal lining
into your muscles you can see the
suckers the suckers also help to anchor
wherever they are living and so
tapeworms are another example of a
parasite well our immune system is
designed to help keep us healthy from
all of these examples of pathogens here
not just tapeworms but all the ones on
the list and so how our pathogens
typically transmitted well that really
depends on the pathogen I'm sure you
know examples of some that might be
carried by water by wind direct contact
and indirect contact look at our
gentlemen on the Left
a - and he sneezes some viruses do you
know the lady on the right was never in
direct contact with that guy but she may
have inhaled some of those viruses that
the gentleman on the Left
sneezed so you know you may have in
direct contact with with a person who
has a sickness some of you may have
direct contact you know for instance if
one of these wrestlers has a fungal rash
a fungal infection on their skin you
know just in the in the activity of a
wrestling match you know you there's
some direct bodily contact that could
possibly spread a fungus infection you
know two of the dirtier things actually
that you touch on a daily basis two
things that you come into direct contact
with on a daily basis with doorknobs and
cellphones you know one's a
last time you cleaned the doorknobs in
your house you know when's the last time
you got a rag sprayed some lice on the
rag and wipe down every doorknob in your
house who does that chances are you
haven't done that ever and you know if
you ever do clean your cellphone the
same thing you may spray some cleaner on
a rag and wipe down your cell phone but
how often do you truly do that so when
we focus on how pathogens are spread
pathogens are or many times Fred by
objects called vectors and we'll go over
some examples you know the first one
let's focus on the disease called
malaria we saw this picture a few
moments ago in the picture is the
Plasmodium organism that causes the
disease malaria but the vector of
malaria you might know to be mosquitoes
so if a mosquito is infected with this
Plasmodium parasite and the mosquito
bites a person good chance that the
mosquito will inject that Plasmodium
into the person and so one thing I want
to clarify is that the species of
mosquito that that spreads malaria
mosquitoes don't cause malaria
mosquitoes can spread the parasite that
causes malaria so there's a little
distinction there I really wanted to
stress mosquitoes don't cause malaria
malaria is caused by the Plasmodium
it's just that mosquitoes can spread the
Plasmodium the bubonic plague you may
have heard of you know killed 50 percent
of Europe couple hundred years ago
caused here's a picture of the cause of
the bubonic plague a bacteria by the
name of your Sania pestis this bacteria
right here caused and still causes
bubonic plague this bacteria is still
around today but it's spread by fleas so
you may have heard from history class
that fleas caused the bubonic plague
well that's not entirely true
I mean fleas spread the bacteria which
caused the bubonic plague
and this examine right here here's a
person's hand with Rocky Mountain
spotted fever now the cause of that rash
that you just saw is a bacteria by the
name of rickets rickets Eddy I think I
said that wrong but this is the bacteria
that causes Rocky Mountain spotted fever
the vector would be ticks so ticks don't
cause Rocky Mountain spotted fever if a
tick bites you it might transfer the
bacteria cholera Caesarea to you and
that's what causes Rocky Mountain
spotted fever okay so now let's actually
look at the parts of your immune system
you know it really does begin with your
skin your skin is often called your
first line of defense of your immune
system because it's a physical barrier
there are various layers to skin to help
keep out foreign pathogens and so not
only are there various layers to our
skin to keep our pathogens but our skin
also produces oils and sweat which can
actually help destroy and kill various
pathogens so here's a you know little
animation of your skin the notes say
that some pathogens will burst and some
will shrivel well here's a bacteria that
just landed on your skin and pretend
that your skin is really oily right now
and so skin oils will actually weaken
the cell membrane of the bacteria and
cause it to burst well here's another
bacteria that just landed on your skin
let's say your skin is really salty
right now because you maybe you've been
sweating a bunch and so salt you might
know dehydrate cells and causes this
particular bacterial cell to shrivel
either way both examples the the
bacteria that landed on the skin died
and so a great example of how our skin
can be a first line of defense well as
we look past our skin you know there's
all these openings to our skin and
bacteria and viruses and fungus they
they can gain entrance to the body
through these various openings
well our openings are surrounded by what
is called a mucous membrane so the
mucous membrane coats the openings and
the exit of the human body so you think
about where are all these openings and
exits of the human body you know the
nose mouth ears eyes genitals anus so
that we have a layer of mucous membranes
that coats and surrounds all these areas
of the body and so you look at here's a
list of items that are commonly inhaled
and in my animation there is a person
that just inhaled those three black dots
but I'm the one on top as a fungus thorn
in the Middle's of bacteria the one on
the bottom is a virus there's a good
chance that these three pathogens will
get stuck in the sticky coating of the
mucous membranes and so they'll never
get past and actually gain access into
the internal cells of your body because
our mucous membranes are lined with a
sticky fluid to trap the pathogens
they're also lined with cilia cell parts
that wave back and forth and ultimately
will lead to you may be sneezing the the
pathogens out or you could actually even
swallow them in to your stomach acids of
your stomach and then they'd be
destroyed but the point is that often
they'll get trapped in the sticky lining
of the mucous membrane and not really go
any further well what happens if viruses
do gain access to the internal parts of
our body we have defense proteins to
help fight these various pathogens so
one form of a defense protein is called
an antibody antibodies are created and
released by a kind of a cell called a
lymphocyte and here's an actual picture
of a lymphocyte we'll talk more about
lymphocytes throughout this video but an
analogy I'd like to make is that
antibody is kind of act like handcuffs
they're gonna attach themselves to a
foreign invader and when we look at
these cute little cartoons here of a
couple of viruses notice how there's
these little bumps on the outside of a
virus well these little objects on the
outside of a virus are called antigens
and they exist on the
side of bacteria as well and what
happens is our lymphocyte will produce
these little handcuff objects called
antibodies those antibodies will attach
to those antigens kind of acts like
handcuffs and that way the the viruses
will be kind of be controlled and locked
into place so they can eventually be
destroyed by other cells of the body so
you're often gonna see antibodies in
textbooks in this video just kind of
shown to look like a letter Y and the
reason for that isn't picture on the
left antibodies are proteins they're
actually in the shape of a letter Y
picture on the left is a fairly
realistic shape drawing of what
antibodies look like so how did they
actually kill well in my animation there
are these Y shaped molecules called
antibodies traveling through our blood
and notice the black and yellow one the
one that's flashing it just attached to
an antigen of the virus on the top you
know my notes say that that antibodies
will cause pathogens to clump so the
antibodies will actually cause those two
viruses to clump together the antibody
is actually holding onto those two
viruses like handcuffs so they're really
trapped they can't spread they can't get
away now that they're trapped and being
held down by the antibodies you have
white blood cells called phagocytes that
kind of resemble my pac-man animation up
here and white blood cell phagocytes
will simply devour the entire cluster
and so that's one way that antibodies
kill they hold on to and trap the
pathogens until they can be devoured by
white blood cell phagocytes another way
that antibodies will fight infection is
they will actually weaken the cell
membrane of the pathogen so here's a
bacterium that's in your blood and
notice how a bunch of antibodies are
attaching to the bacterium poking little
holes in the cell membrane of the
bacteria eventually causing the bacteria
to burst
so there's another great way that
antibodies can can actually destroy
foreign invaders
another type of defense protein I want
to mention it's called interferon
there's two cells but watch what happens
the cell on the left has just become
infected with a virus the virus has
injected its RNA and new viruses are
being created sadly the cell on the left
is infected and it's gonna die there's
really no way to save it so step two of
this process the cell on the left is
gonna release a defense protein by the
name of interferon now in the word
interfere and I hope you can see the
word interfere so clearly this
interferon is gonna interfere with
something so the infected cell releases
interferon and notice the healthy cell
on the right received the interferon the
healthy cell on the right is then gonna
begin to create defense enzymes
illustrated by my animated scissors here
so the animated scissors are
representing the defense enzymes created
as a result of receiving interferon and
unfortunately the cell on the left is
gonna be destroyed but the healthy cell
on the right it's gonna be able to fight
the virus now so watch this our healthy
excuse me our infected cell the infected
cell was just destroyed and as those new
viruses try to infect the cell to the
right the defense enzymes the animated
scissors are destroying the new viruses
it helps to keep the cell on the right
healthy and not become infected that's
kind of just a neat little animation of
what interferon can do alright so I'm
sure you've heard of types of cells
called white blood cells and in the
picture there's a red blood cell on the
left and then there's a cell in the
middle and a cell on the right sound the
middle and the cell on the right are
different kinds of white blood cells and
in general the job of white blood cells
are to search and destroy now there's
various kinds of white blood cells so
let's mention a few a few of them so one
of the types of white blood cells I want
to mention are what are called
phagocytes and like the notes say they
surrounded
Gulf invaders through the process of
phagocytosis you know there's a virus
right in the middle of our blood vein
and here comes a white blood cell
phagocyte through the process of
phagocytosis that phagocytes gonna begin
to surround and devour that virus notice
how the virus is trapped it's trapped
inside of a lysosome but it's still
alive
well what's kind of neat is that
digestive efore enzymes will be placed
inside the lysosome and ultimately that
will destroy the virus so that's one way
that phagocytes helped patrol our body
and prevent us from becoming sick here's
a real neat thing that a neat skill that
phagocytes have let's say that you're
walking home from school one day and you
don't see that rusty nail sticking out
of a fence and you accidentally brush
your shoulder against it and you cut
your skin well that can now be a way for
maybe bacteria to enter your skin well
watch this white blood cell phagocytes
actually have the ability to squeeze out
of your bloodstream crawl over to where
the bacteria is devour it through
phagocytosis so white blood cells don't
have to just stay in your blood they can
actually exit your blood crawl to where
the invader is and destroy it another
type of a second type of white blood
cell I want to mention I want to call
them lymphocytes now there's two
different kinds of lymphocytes I want to
briefly mention one of them are called
b-cell lymphoma the letter B right here
now I'm b-cell emphasized are not
actually shaped like the letter B
they're called B cells because they
mature in your bone marrow but I just
wanted to animate and illustrate them as
the letter B for B for a B cell and
they're creating these y-shaped proteins
called antibodies and then watch watch
the the antibody that's flashing so the
B cells gonna release a bunch of
antibodies but again the flashing
antibody has attached to an antigen to
the virus on the left that will cause
the two viruses to clump together
remember that
antibodies kind of act like handcuffs
and so now that these two viruses are
clumped together a phagocyte will come
and devour the whole group through
phagocytosis so there's one a benefit of
what b-cell and besides do so the other
type of lymphocyte I want to mention and
what are called t-cell lymphocytes now
t-cells you see they're travelling in
our blood now they do not actually
resemble the letter T I'm just being
symbolic of a t-cell they're called
t-cells because they mature and you're
famous it's a gland called your thymus
and so what t-cells do is they destroy
any cells that may have become infected
so let me show you what I mean
here's to red blood cells you have a
healthy red blood cell on the left but
you have an infected red blood cell on
the right and notice how the infected
red blood cell on the right there's
antigens of the parasite there's
antigens of the invader sticking out of
the red blood cell that's actually very
realistic of what happens in real life
so T cells will you know travel through
your blood and if they encounter a
healthy red blood cell there's no
antigens of the invader sticking out of
it so there's no reason to attack the T
cell moves on and now the T cells come
to the infected red blood cell remember
the infected red blood cell has antigens
of the attacker sticking out of it well
the T cell will see those antigens and
it will release a bunch of efore enzymes
onto the infected red blood cell sadly
it's gonna kill your own body cell but
it will also kill the infected
it'll kill the infection the the
pathogen that was causing the infection
as well the T cell then moves on and
continues so as I wrap up this video I
want to mention what a vaccination is
first of all the vaccination is designed
to prevent you from getting sick in the
first place it's not designed to cure
you if you become sick
so the newspaper clippings are from 1955
the gentlemen the picture created a
vaccine for polio polio is a virus
infection where where sadly people who
are infected with this particular virus
the virus destroys cells of the nervous
system and ultimately can lead to
paralysis and eventually death well when
we look at what the vaccination process
is here we see a young man a young child
being injected with a vaccine some
vaccines are injected some are pills
some of are even eyedrops and so a
weekend the pathogen is being injected
into this little boy and so in our
little cartoon here we're gonna inject
this little kid with with a vaccination
we're gonna inject them with a weakened
version of a virus perhaps and now that
we've done that the immune system is
gonna produce a couple of things you
know let's zoom on into this kid's arm
and see what's going on and at the
cellular level so now that we've zoomed
down into the kid we can see that we've
injected this kid with a bunch of dead
viruses now they're dead so they're not
going to hurt the kid
but our immune system doesn't know that
they're dead our immune system is gonna
see these foreign invaders and think
that they that it needs to attack so
what's gonna happen is that there's a
b-cell remember what b-cells make they
make antibodies there's a b-cell and
it's gonna make a bunch of antibodies
and it's gonna release these antibodies
into your blood and even though the
viruses are already dead they're gonna
be destroyed even further so now we have
antibodies more antibodies in our blood
to fight infection a second thing that's
gonna happen is memory cells are going
to be made for future infections those B
cells that were made are gonna multiply
and those memory b-cells are going to
multiply and so this makes basically a
reserved group of b-cells should you
ever encounter the real
and so the goal is to make these memory
cells and the goals to make these
antibodies and be ten depending on the
vaccination some of these memory cells
and antibodies you'll keep for life
depending on the vaccination others you
might need a booster maybe every 10 or
20 years but the purpose is let's say 30
years go by what happens if you were to
recatch not the dead virus but if you
were to recatch the living virus well
the good news is you already have
antibodies you already have memory cells
that were created 30 years ago when you
were vaccinated that will hopefully
recognize that living virus and attack
it so there you go there's a real brief
introduction on the immune system you
know go ahead and pause this video
especially if you're in my class and put
your answers on the separate sheet of
paper I'd love to check them before
school or after school for accuracy good
luck